[Musique]
ce soir pour parler de cette visite des
chefs c'est Michel David Michel CEG
Christian Dufour alors on va regarder
ces images ça s'est passé plutôt
aujourd'hui c'était pas juste monsieur
Legault c'est l'ensemble des chefs de
parties du Québec le qui était sur place
pour serrer des mains pour écouter pour
échanger avoir des mots de confession ce
qui est troublant c'est toujours cet air
de déjà vu parce que il y a pas très
longtemps on faisait exactement madame
la même chose mais on le faisait à Laval
est-ce qu'on trouve les bons mots est-ce
que c'est un exercice réussi Michel
David à vos yeux
c'est un exercice imposé je dirais et
c'est toujours les mêmes mots qu'on
répète parce que il y a pas grand chose
d'autre à dire quand les gens sont
frappés par une tragédie comme celle-là
il y a pas 50 choses qu'on peut leur
dire manifester de la sympathie écouter
aussi et c'est ce que monsieur Legault a
fait un acte de contrition qui qui est
le bienvenu sans doute c'est vrai qu'il
y a pas assez de ressources en santé
mentale mais c'est une problématique qui
qui dépasse largement le cas de coup ou
celui de Laval alors c'est un exercice
réussi mais
il y a pas 50 six façons de faire la
chose Christian ce que nous rapporte nos
collègues qui étaient sur place c'est
qu'il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
citoyens qui sont déplacés la presse
d'ailleurs c'est une femme vikiduette
qui dit c'est surprenante voir tous ces
gens aiment que oui on sent visible
alors qu'on a souvent l'impression
d'être invisible votre réaction je
trouve que l'émotion est au rendez-vous
puis comment ça pourrait être autrement
parce que c'est une tragédie humaine
terrible ça nous aime tous c'est normal
que les chefs politiques soient là je te
dis moi je suis un peu mal à l'aise par
la décla au chef de la littérature de
Monsieur le groupe qui peut être contre
des dépenses plus grandes en matière de
santé mentale mais il me semble que là
c'est un moment de grande grande émotion
on n'a pas en fait d'informations
précises rigoureuses sur ce qui est
arrivé à moukoui le Premier ministre
c'est pas n'importe qui il fait un peu
comme Monsieur bonardelle ils s'avance
il nous dit que dans quelques jours dans
le budget il va avoir des dépenses pour
la santé
euh mental dans une société et là je
repasse sûrement interpréter là j'ai
énormément de sympathie pour ce qui
arrive à me cuit mais il faut dire ce
qu'on pense je trouve qu'au Québec on
est très privilégié c'est une société
qui a tendance je trouve à s'adresser
toujours à l'état donc un problème
processus de déresponsabilisation et
d'infantilisation donc quel premier
ministre aujourd'hui alors que l'émotion
énorme alors qu'on a quand même pas
d'information rigoureuse disent bah là
il faut qu'il y ait plus de dépenses à
santé mentale on va en parler dans le
budget peut-être c'est déjà prévu dans
le budget mais moi ça m'a un peu mal à
l'aise Michel C est-ce qu'effectivement
il va un petit peu vite monsieur Lego
sur cet enjeu et votre avis
écoutez le budget doit être déjà imprimé
alors il est un fort probable qu'il
sache très bien ce que dans le budget
puis qu'il y aura quelque chose dans le
bus j'espère la première fois qu'on dit
qu'il manque de ressources en santé
mentale c'est pas c'est pas une
nouveauté qu'on vient de découvrir à
cause de aujourd'hui cuit loin de là et
il dit aujourd'hui parce que là
aujourd'hui et moi je vois pas de
grandes que je trouve bien par exemple
c'est la présence de tous les chefs de
parties je sais que ça maintenant ça
fait un peu rituel puis tout le monde
fait toujours comme ça mais dans une
société qui qui aime à se décrire comme
étant tricoter serrer là le fait que
tous les courants politiques soient là
avec le Premier ministre
non seulement c'est du réconfort pour
les gens parce qu'ils vont se retrouver
nécessairement mais c'est une façon de
dire on est tous ensemble avec vous moi
je pense que c'est c'est important et
c'est un c'est un geste fort que la
classe politique pose sur les questions
santé mentale effectivement on y arrive
on avait préparé des extraits pour que
les gens nous suivent dans la discussion
on va écouter monsieur Legault parce que
il a parlé de santé mentale mais il a
parlé de son sentiment de culpabilité
dans cet enjeu aussi on l'écoute
évidemment on a de la difficulté à
trouver les mots
on sent un peu coupable en tout cas moi
le premier en me disant mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire de plus puis on doit en
faire plus pour la santé mentale c'est
pas toujours facile parce qu'il faut que
les personnes acceptent
d'aller chercher de l'aide
des fois faut peut-être les forcer à
aller chercher de l'aide
je le David sont décortique un peu il y
a plusieurs choses là-dedans parce que
d'abord on parle d'un coup oui c'est pas
un grand centre puis il y a bien des
endroits au Québec qui ont qui ont le
même problématique qui aime quiz c'est à
dire que pour avoir accès par exemple un
psychiatre un suivi en santé mentale ben
il faut faire de la route il faut faire
dans le cas d'un coup une heure de route
pour se rendre à Rimouski et monsieur
Legault aussi dit pas tout le monde qui
accepte l'aide alors là c'est l'autre
enjeu jusqu'où on va jusqu'où on force
quelqu'un il y a une loi en ce moment
est-ce que c'est la bonne est-ce qu'il
faut la changer bref il ouvre plusieurs
portes
c'est loin de Rimouski mais il y a 20
000 personnes là sur les listes
d'attentes partout au Québec en attente
de voir un psychologue alors avoir santé
mentale de façon générale alors c'est
pas unique à me couille puis c'est pour
rien qu'une question de distance
maintenant est-ce que monsieur Legault
je sais pas ce qu'il y avait en tête
dire forcer les gens à consulter il me
semble cette avancé un peu loin d'avoir
qui on consulte parce que c'est pas
évident de savoir qui aurait besoin
d'une consultation alors ça je suis pas
certain qu'il y a qui s'est un peu sur
quoi sur quel terrain il s'avance mais
maintenant
est-ce que parce que Monsieur karma on a
parlé lui aussi et lui est plus disons
au fait en principe de ce qui se passe
dit que par exemple dans un endroit
comme couille il y aurait moyen et ça
s'appliquerait j'imagine à d'autres à
d'autres régions de de reniper un peu si
vous voulez les
clsc'était c'est une bonne idée c'est
probablement dans beaucoup de casses qui
est le plus près mais encore là les
psychologues là il y a une pénurie
généralisée de psychologue alors s'il y
en manque à Montréal si on peut penser
quand même couille ça sera pas évident
dans recruter alors les solutions là ce
qu'il faudrait faire je pense qu'on sait
pas mal la question c'est de savoir
comment on peut faire ça et on sert
toujours au même problème aujourd'hui je
trouve que c'est la journée du réconfort
de l'émotion mais tout ça manque
singulièrement de rigueur
il me semble que tu décides pas d'une
politique publique à partir simplement
de l'émotion et d'un cas je m'excuse de
revenir là-dessus je le répète j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour ce qui est
arrivé mais moi je suis profondément mal
à l'aise Premier ministre c'est pas
n'importe qui là c'est pas Christian du
four c'est Julie de envoyer un message
sociétal quand il dit je me sens
coupable moi je trouve ça renforce
quelque chose qui existe trop au Québec
me répète une société très très
privilégiée ou de plus en plus on a le
réflexe de dire c'est de la faute du
gouvernement c'est de la faute du
gouvernement on le sait pas il y a pas
encore dans laquelle donc qui soit là
tant mieux mais le Premier ministre
s'avance beaucoup je trouve trop oui
très vêtements bon ce qui le dit aussi
quand il a parlé du budget qu'il a parlé
des services qui vont avoir plus de
financement il a quand même soulevé
quelque chose si vous savez on a quand
même des postes qu'on n'arrive pas à
combler ça aussi mais je le sais sur un
jeu qui est important c'est un peu comme
les postes infirmières c'est un peu
comme il y en a tellement là où on se
dit les enseignants ont dit j'ai de
l'argent je ferai ouvrir des postes mais
je trouve pas de gens non plus
la pénurie de main d'oeuvre est un
problème qui va aller s'en s'accentuant
qui va devenir un des problèmes
principaux de la société québécoise dans
tous les secteurs pas juste en santé
mentale il faut juste en éducation ça va
être à peu près partout alors ça il faut
une politique plus
détaché des événements si vous voulez
cohérente là-dessus non on travaille
là-dessus beaucoup à la pièce et c'est
pas le temps d'une situation comme
celle-là pour venir un peu sur ce que je
dis ça disait c'est pas le temps non
plus pour le Premier ministre de faire
exactement ce que monsieur bodarden a
fait la veille c'est à dire de penser
tout haut puis dire ah il faudrait les
obliger à s'entraider d'abord une
obligation de traitement c'est pas dans
la loi au Québec puis c'était pas c'est
pas le moment de faire ça le moment le
moment de personne c'est de dire là on a
un problème de pénurie de batterie c'est
clair qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ça
comment on va réussir à avec des moyens
que l'on donne les moyens de personnel
à servir tout le monde et ça c'est
vraiment très important de commencer à
réfléchir à ça pas nécessairement dans
une crise dans une situation de deuil
comme ça je vous amène sur un autre
sujet qui reste lié quand même au monde
de la santé c'est cette idée du ministre
de la Santé Christian Dubé qui veut
permettre au Québécois d'évaluer la
qualité des services qu'ils reçoivent
quand ils vont dans un établissement de
santé donc c'est un questionnaire en
ligne il y a déjà des projets pilotes on
va déjà avoir des résultats à partir la
semaine prochaine donc on évalue de 0 à
10 si on trouvait que les délais étaient
acceptables de ce service était
respectueux sur un temps de poser nos
questions alors ça c'est les exemples
qui nous ont été donnés ça ce que c'est
une bonne idée est-ce que vous vous
feriez ça évaluer votre médecin évaluer
votre séjour à l'urgence
autour de moi pour les gens me disaient
coudors il sait pas que les gens une
mauvaise opinion du système de santé
qu'est-ce qu'il lui faut je te dis de
toute façon plus sérieuse bon dans la
mesure où le gouvernement veut agir dans
ce secteur là bon ça peut se défendre en
fait de demander aux gens sur quel point
précis en fait il y a une INSAT on nous
dit souvent que le problème c'est
d'entrer dans le système de santé Quand
tu es dans le système de santé beaucoup
de gens disent qu'on est très très bien
traités au Québec donc c'est une
démarche qui peut se comprendre mais
reste la réaction de beaucoup de monde
la première réaction du coup de montre
s'il te plaît dans le sens de ce que
j'ai dit non c'est un domaine où
vraiment il y a un espèce d'unanimité on
l'a vu durant la pandémie que des gros
gros problèmes donc peut-être il faut y
aller toute façon les positif mais
Michel David ça va mettre quand même
d'impression sur ses propres épaules le
monsieur Dubé parce qu'effectivement si
les notes sont bases c'est quand même
lui qui est ministre de santé oui mais
vous savez monsieur Duby c'est un
hyperactif et là j'ai souvent
l'impression que il multiplie les
initiatives pour vous montrer et voyez
je fais quelque chose j'essaye de régler
les affaires ça donne pas toujours des
résultats mais au moins ça donne
l'impression qu'il essaie dans ce cas-ci
le position a créé au show de Boucan bon
c'est peut-être un peu exagéré comme
expression mais honnêtement je suis pas
certain que ça va apporter grand chose à
l'amélioration des services comme disait
Christian on le sait c'est quoi le
problème en général et vous savez les
données là il y a juste je regardais
tantôt il y a une mise à jour qui se
fait la dernière elle s'est fait 17
heures 19 à pas longtemps là on sait
exactement le combien il y a de monde
dans les urgences combien ça prend de
temps alors on peut facilement présumer
que dans l'hôpital où ça prend avec 18h
pour passer là les gens seront pas
contents puis quand ça prend trois
heures ils vont être plus content alors
je vois pas tellement le
comment le but vraiment d'amélioration
de cette mesure là mais est-ce que ça
peut être un peu plus à moyen ou long
terme Michel cycle c'est-à-dire que
Monsieur Dubé s'en vient aussi avec un
projet de loi il va créer une agence de
la santé alors c'est il parlait beaucoup
on veut que les gens soient imputables
on veut avoir l'occasion peut-être de
tasser quelqu'un si on trouve qu'il fait
pas la faire comme gestionnaire alors
finalement c'est mauvais résultat s'il y
en avait dans ces sondages là ça
pourrait nuire à certaines carrières de
gens qui travaillent dans le monde de la
santé
actuellement le gouvernement il y a une
mode au gouvernement c'est les tableaux
de bord on va avoir des tableaux de bord
sur tout le Conseil du Trésor en
affectateur sur l'efficacité des
ministères là on va faire un basé sur
des sondages sur ce qui se passe dans le
service de santé d'abord ça peut être
très subjectif là c'est déjà est-ce que
vous avez trois attendu parce que
comment on répond cette question-là
alors je suis pas sûr que ça va aider
tant que ça je suis d'accord avec mon
ami Michel que Monsieur Dubé il faut
qu'il fasse une annonce toutes les trois
jours parce que sinon ça sent pas bien
là mais à un moment avoir
des résultats de son âge je suis sûr que
ça donne une idée de ce client elle
passe mais je suis pas sûr que c'est
extrêmement scientifique non plus
espérons qu'ils vont sonder des gens
dans les urgence
pas sûr du genre de résultat qu'on va
avoir la moyenne sera pas forte mais on
peut faire ça comme ça
aujourd'hui alors ce qu'on comprend
finalement c'est qu'on renouvelle
finalement le l'attestation qui permet
l'affondrer continuer à opérer on met
des conditions mais ce qu'on dit c'est
les émissions d'arsenic là d'ici 5 ans
il faut que baisse à 15 nanogrammes on a
demandé au ministre mais pourquoi on
attend 5 ans voici la réponse qui nous
donnait aujourd'hui
un travail de moine littéralement qui a
été fait par les experts du ministère de
l'Environnement pour mesurer les
différentes étapes nécessaires et on
était arrivé à la conclusion ce n'était
tout simplement pas possible d'y aller
plus rapidement c'est sûr que c'est une
autorisation qui très ambitieuse mais on
l'accueille de façon favorable on va
mettre tous les efforts les gens sont
mobilisés puis on peut atteindre les
objectifs
est-ce que c'est acceptable est-ce qu'on
était assez ambitieux qu'on demande à
une entreprise multimilliardaire comme
Glen qui appartient la fonderie World à
Michel C la deuxième on vous donne 5 ans
pour arriver à une norme qui reste quand
même pas la norme que les autres
Québécois ont parce que on rappelons que
la norme au Québec C3
je vais le féminisme respecter les
normes québécoises le vrai mot c'est
respecté la loi alors à Rouen la
fonderie
de ne pas respecter la loi ça c'est un
problème ça fait longtemps qu'on le sait
je sais que ça va être difficile de
faire le travail à l'intérieur je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ça mais il y a
quelque chose quand même de de ce qu'est
le dernier là pas durable voici une
multination on va leur donner un petit
coup de temps pour s'habituer à nos lois
et tout ça alors que en même temps on va
reloger des gens qui sont dans le
quartier pour aider la fonderie ordre et
ça c'est une solution qui n'a pas le
rapport était présenté quand il y a une
consultation publique alors il y a
vraiment là deux trois deux mesures
entre ce qui arrive avec les citoyens
qui arrivent avec la compagnie Michel
David là-dessus ouais mais moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un aveu
d'impuissance complètement à écouter on
déplace les gens ça ça veut dire qu'on
sait parfaitement que le 15 nanogramme
on n'est pas sûr de et que le 3
nanogramme parce qu'on dit il faut que
la compagnie présente un plan 2027 et il
y a aucun échéancier on sait que ça
arrivera pas le droit alors c'est pour
ça qu'on déplace les gens alors dans le
fond c'est un espèce de démission
on fait une zone tampon autour de
l'usine parce qu'on sait parfaitement
que les on atteindra jamais un niveau où
la santé va des gens vont être assurés
un agent qui vont coûter cher au
gouvernement parce qu'en tout et pour
tout avec les comités qu'on met sur pied
tout ça c'est 88 millions quand même
d'argent du Québec qui va dépenser
là-dessus Christian commentaire
là-dessus j'ai rarement vu un dossier
aussi technique franchement j'ai lu
trois fois les documents de Radio-Canada
j'ai pas compris grand chose donc je
parlerai pas du côté technique moi ce
qui m'intéresse plus c'est le plan
d'action là pour reloger les gens les
200 familles ça c'est vrai je trouve
qu'on le fait de façon un peu cavalière
et de façon pas suffisamment
transparente je pense que c'est comme ça
ça donne l'impression que plus la
compagnie que du bien-être des gens je
te dis rappel quand même que la santé
publique du Québec et de la région
trouve que c'est un plan qui se déforme
c'était la proposition de la santé
publique effectivement Christian avait
raison de le dire on va se laisser
là-dessus merci beaucoup merci à vous
trois d'avoir été avec nous bonne soirée
au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI